alors justement on vous retrouve
dominique en direct a lyon quelques
minutes après l annonce de ce verdict
est ce que l'institution judiciaire ne
risque pas de sortir secoué de cet
épisode deux condamnations à la
perpétuité et puis finalement après 15
ans un acquittement
oui on peut parler presque deux séismes
le mot est à la mode en ce moment c'est
vrai que l'institution judiciaire va
probablement avoir à réfléchir à ce qui
s'est passé au cours de ses 15 ans elle
va se défendre en disant que après tout
elle a fonctionné puisque aujourd'hui
une cour d'assises dès mineurs du rhône
a acquitté patrick 10 ce qui va se
passer aussi c'est qu'il va y avoir
j'allais dire une propre mise en cause
de patrick dils lui même parce qu'avant
il est comme l'a dit lui-même son avocat
il est coupable d'avoir avoué et d'avoir
entraîné donc la justice sur sur une
erreur d'avoir entretenu en quelques
instants quelque sorte cette injustice
et d'avoir pris selon les mots de
l'avocat général hier la place d'un
autre meurtrier un autre meurtrier qu'il
va falloir chercher alors on le suspecte
c'est francis paul ça veut dire que
demain est bien le parquet général de
metz va peut-être pouvoir ouvrir une
information judiciaire et réouvrir le
dossier du double crime de
montigny-lès-metz parce que ce soir et
bien ses deux enfants sont morts mais on
ne connaît pas le coupable dominique
encore un mot des réactions vous évoquez
des applaudissements tout à l'heure on
les entend on les entend encore
d'ailleurs
y at il eu aussi des réactions de
consternation da par des familles des
victimes
écoutez les parents des deux petites
victimes ne sont pas présentes là au
moment du verdict dans la salle
simplement la grand-mère est présentée
elle avait laissé entendre avant que si
c'était un acquittement et bien pour
elles ont libéré un assassin mais vous
l'entendez vous le voyez probablement
également derrière moi c'est
l'applaudissement c'est la joie qui ici
règne à la cour d'assises du rhône merci
dominique pour ce compte rendu en direct
patrick dils donc est donc acquitté au
terme de son troisième procès